[Applause]
the last man your age to cause this kind
of excitement I gotta think is Mick
Jagger and also you know after the
debate Google reported that you were the
most clicked-on name people more people
were searching for you than Justin
Bieber's penis so you must be gratified
about all this going on my question to
you I guess is the word socialist I want
to get right to this because I want to
help your campaign I want to see you get
that on that issue I want to see you we
have to not do it we have to teach
Americans what this is we don't and I I
don't know if we're doing that yet
because I don't think most Americans
realize they're already socialists in
certain respects okay let's start off
with what it is not what we want to
change we want to deal with the
grotesque level of income and wealth
inequality in America very few people
think it's acceptable or moral that the
top one-tenth of one percent owns almost
as much wealth as the bottom 90% that we
have seen Apple afford but see Bernie
you always say that and I think even
though even the Republicans are not for
income inequality they hear that but it
doesn't compute that that's gonna be
solved by socialism socialism is the
program's they already like they like
Social Security that socialists are here
they like Medicare they like the VA they
like the military that's exactly right
it's already a socialist couple we have
to know it's not of socialism
it's quasi quasi there are some
socialist programs but what we have got
to do is remind fellow Americans that
every other major country on Earth
guarantees health care to all people as
a right and they do it more
cost-effective illegal
we have got to inform the American
people that we are the only major
country on Earth that doesn't guarantee
paid family and medical leave we have
got to remind the American people that
there's something a little bit crazy
when in America we have more people in
jail disproportionately people of color
than any other major country on earth I
don't know if we're still under mine
izing this word socialism this is my big
thing tonight to get you to undermine
eyes this word because you know they do
polls on who people would vote for like
would people vote for a woman a Jew a
black those are in like the low 90s like
90 to 91 percent of the people know of
course the other 8% I think we know who
those people are you won't be getting
their vote then like 75% of Americans
would now vote for a gay person that's a
big change from 10 years ago 60% would
vote for a Muslim 58% would vote for an
atheist socialist 47 it's at the very
bottom what we have to hear socialists
they think herpes Bernie you had we have
to represent what we do is we have to
make the movement if you like to
correlate what we're talking about
because on every one of the major issues
I am talking about the American people
agree do the American people agree that
public colleges and universities should
be tuition free as they are in many
other countries
right here the American people believe
that the largest corporations and the
wealthiest people who today are doing
phenomenally well while the middle class
shrinks do people believe they should be
asked to pay more in taxes the American
people say yes okay but now this has
been studied the amount of tax revenue
that we would get just from taxing the
people who I think your fans think
you're talking about the people who own
a yacht does not come close to covering
what you want to pay for it's not true
not true come on you're saying by only
taxing the top now what I'm saying is
there have been articles out there that
have been really unfair and wonk for
example what they are suggesting if we
move toward a medicare-for-all
single-payer program which guarantees
health care to all people
it would cost a lot of money that's true
but what they forget to tell you is it
would be much more cost effective than
the dysfunctional system we have right
now which is the most expensive per
capita on earth but it couldn't even
work in your home state of Vermont they
were going to institute it and and the
governor said it's gonna cost too much
money we just can't do it it would be
the entire budget no well that well
that's true well let's not I'm not the
governor of the state of Vermont I'm the
senator from the state of Vermont but he
looked then the question is built you
tell me why is it that every other major
country on I will tell you what because
they control both ends of it we're if
you're saying that the government is
gonna pick up the tab but not make the
insurance companies the hospitals and
the doctors not gouge peope right then
we are gonna break the budget it has to
work both exactly ok so then your third
example our here's the new so you're
gonna make the hospitals do that you're
gonna do it because that the United
States is the only major country on
earth that allows private insurance
companies to make huge profits in the
healthcare system right the function of
health care should be to provide quality
care to all people not to make huge
profits of the drug companies and
insurance companies but so
here is my point here is my point we are
spending more per capita on health care
than any other major country on earth
our health care outcomes are not
particularly good and I believe that
health care should be a right of all
people ok but you want you want to
increase Social Security yes and you
know how we do that we pay for it right
we say that somebody who's making 10
million should not end up paying the
same amount of somebody making a hundred
and eighteen thousand look at the cap we
can extend that expand Social Security
okay you also on free college yeah
that's right what's that one we do not
free called a public college spread pre
tuition at public colleges universities
you know how we pay for that through a
tax on Wall Street speculation okay
child care yup child care yes and single
pair now Segal payer is more cost
effective than what we have right now in
terms of child care in terms of
rebuilding our crumbling infrastructure
and creating millions of decent-paying
jobs we do do away with these huge tax
loopholes they're corporations as well
so you're saying we can pay for all this
without raising taxes on anybody but the
1% may have to go down a little bit
lower than that but not much lower but
that's
you